Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
What languages does the Pope speak?
I want to talk about polyglot pope's.
When you think of the pope,
you might think of a very holy person,
a religious person,
someone who sits around praying all day
or something like that,
but think about it.
To be the leader of a huge organization
like the Catholic Church,
do you have to be a very success minded,
driven then accomplished individually,
so let's look at a few recent folks and
see where they rate on the polyglot
scale.
First,
let's talk about the current pope.
Pope Francis,
who became the pope in 2013.
He is originally from Argentina and he
speaks Spanish fluently as his native
language.
He also speaks Italian fluently.
He learned Italian as a kid when he was
in Argentina from his father and his
grandparents who were Italian immigrants
and early on when he became the pope at
the beginning,
he would only speak Italian in public
for the media or in front of audiences.
Italian is the Lingua Franca of the
Vatican and it's the most commonly
spoken language in the Vatican,
and also he is the arch bishop of Rome,
so it makes sense that he would speak
Italian,
the language of his own locality.
I've also heard reports from Brazilian
people that when Pope Francis visited
Brazil,
he spoke fluently in Portuguese,
although with a heavy Argentinian accent
and apparently the pope speaks also
German and French,
but he is getting rusty due to a lack of
use.
Pope Francis also admits that he's had
quite a hard time learning English in
large part due to English phonology,
which he finds hard during a three month
stay in Ireland.
When he tried to learn English,
he had some trouble.
Although I must say I can't blame him
for being confused by the Irish people.
Funny Pronunciation.
Sorry.
Irish people.
Just kidding.
After being the pope for a little over a
year,
Pope Francis spoke English in public for
the first time in Seoul,
Korea to say yes.
So
clearly Pope Francis is working on his
English and he's improving it to be able
to do his duties better around the
world.
Of course,
he also knows Latin which is used for
ceremonial purposes and for official
documents in the Vatican and part of his
studies was also filling in biblical
Hebrew and biblical Greek,
which are necessary for Bible study.
So Pope Francis speaks Spanish,
Italian,
Portuguese,
some German,
some French,
some English,
and three literary languages for a total
polyglot score of six out of 10.
That's pretty darn good by the way,
but he's up against some stiff
competition so I can't give him 10 out
of 10.
Next is pope benedict the 16th who was
the pope from 2005 until 2013 when he
resigned.
He is known for being more of a
legitimate polyglot.
Then Pope Francis,
his native language is German,
but he is also known to fluently speak
Italian,
French,
English and Spanish.
I've also read reports that he speaks
Portuguese,
but not totally fluently,
but he's very good at Latin and used
Latin more than Pope Francis currently
does as pope,
and of course he can also read biblical
Hebrew and biblical Greek,
but again,
they're not spoken languages.
Those are just classical written
languages.
Pope Benedict made waves in 2013 when he
resigned as the pope,
which is almost completely unheard of,
and he made waves partly because his
announcement was in Latin.
The reporter who broke the story to the
world ended up being the only reporter
in the Vatican press office who could
understand the original report in Latin.
So let's recap for a pope benedict the
16th.
He speaks German,
Italian,
Spanish,
French,
and English fluently.
He also speaks some Portuguese and he
speaks lesson he knows to literary
languages,
Greek and Biblical Hebrew for right
total polyglot score of seven out of 10,
but the king of polyglot pope's is
without a doubt.
Pope John Paul the second who was the
pope from 1978 until his death in 2005.
Pope John Paul the second was originally
from Poland.
So his native language was Polish,
but he was also fluent in Italian,
Spanish,
Portuguese,
French and English as well as Latin.
Of course,
Pope John Paul the second is also known
for having a good working knowledge of
some other languages,
at least enough to speak publicly in
those languages with some preparation.
Those languages include Slovak,
Russian,
Ukrainian,
Japanese,
Tagalog,
among many others.
At the end of one Easter mass,
he once gave an Easter greeting in 57
different languages.
Maybe he loved languages so much because
he was also an avid traveler.
He visited 129 different countries,
which is more than any other point in
history.
So to recap,
Pope John Paul the second was fluent in
Polish,
Italian,
Spanish,
Portuguese,
French,
English and German and Latin.
Auntie do a whole bunch of other
languages better than most language
dabblers out there.
So he gets a total polyglot score of 10
out of 10,
whether you're a Catholic or not.
Pope John Paul,
the second was clearly uninspiring,
polyglot and his language lovers.
We can look up to and admire that aspect
of his life and his work.
Thank you for watching the length.
Focus.
Gentle.
Have a good night.